particularly if you're saying whiteness
is a thing that is being constructed as
negative and shouldn't be name something
positive that you like about being white
there's a lot of documents that are
floating around public schools that say
things like uh timeliness showing up on
time is a white supremacist value or a
white Value white dominant value things
like rationality things like the
Enlightenment and uh these are very
strange things to be ascribed to a
racial identity my view is that these
are actually should be ascribed to every
individual human being every individual
human being regardless of whatever
racial category we impose on them name
something positive about being that you
believe is positive about being white
again I don't buy into the framework
that the world can be reduced into these
metaphysical categories of whiteness and
Blackness who who is the racist in that
conversation who is trying to racialize
everything and who's trying to
de-racialize everything